we want to go to an exclusive interview
with CBS News it's with Democratic
presidential hopeful Elizabeth Warren
who insists that she was fired from a
teaching job nearly fifty years ago
because she was pregnant a series of
reports have questioned the story she's
been telling on the campaign trail but
the senator responded on Twitter
overnight reading stories of other women
who say they were victims of pregnancy
discrimination
a new poll this week shows Warren
narrowly leading the Democratic race
over former Vice President Joe Biden ed
O'Keefe is covering campaign 2020 he's
in Manchester New Hampshire and I don't
think anyone doubts that pregnancy
discrimination exists so what are the
questions about Warren's story in
particular sure Tony good morning the
issue here is a key part of Warren's
life story why she left a job as a
schoolteacher and how it set her on her
course to run for president questions of
the legitimacy of the story stem in part
from claims she's made in the past about
her heritage but in this case Warren
says she stands by her story they said
you don't a great job come back next
year and when they found out I was
pregnant they changed that senator
Elizabeth Warren is defending a story
she often touts on the campaign trail
the principal did what principals did in
those days wished me luck and hired
someone else for the job she paints a
picture of the path she reluctantly took
into public service after claiming she
was fired from her first teaching job in
New Jersey in 1971 while six months
pregnant they wish to walk showed you
the door and hired someone else for the
job but some have questioned her version
of events pointing to a 2007 interview
where she gave a different reason for
why she left I actually didn't have the
education courses so I was on an
emergency certificate it was called and
I went back to graduate school and took
a couple of courses in education and
said I don't think this is going to work
out for me and minutes from school board
meetings show Warren's resignation was
accepted with regret it doesn't matter
much what the term is but let's be clear
I was six months pregnant it was my
first job I was 22 years old and the job
that was mine that I'd been hired for
for the next year
was taken away when they knew I was
pregnant questions about her employment
history come after years of scrutiny
over her claims of Native American
ancestry which she apologized for over
the summer now Warren says she
understands the fresh scrutiny of her
background I think of how this resonates
with so many millions of women across
this country and people who've been in
if not that exact situation similar
situations our months long investigation
also led us to to a Warren's former
teaching colleagues who say they have no
recollection of anyone being fired at
that time but that Warren would have had
no choice but to leave the job because
she was pregnant all of this happened
about seven years before passage of the
federal Pregnancy Discrimination Act
Anthony all right ed thank you very much